[Music]  [Music]  oh  go  [Music]  um  very natural but of course i am  i used to live my life a quarter mile at  a time what are you smiling about  dude almost had you i could never say i  did it  but i did it for those 10 seconds or  less  let's make some money right or done  i was free  now hey man i hold  on to what's real absolutely familiar  this right here takes crazy to a whole  nother level  my family i'd ride to the death with you  but no matter how much roads behind you  you cannot run your past  and mine been a long time little brother  [Music]  there's nothing more dangerous time to  kill your family  i'm ready if you are yeah  i'm my brother but you will never  be a family  [Music]  [Music]  you